with poor a Justin gaichi do you see it
going different you know they find 2018.
I was one of these guys who was like
well maybe father time and all that
damage because listen I mean the first
guy who will tell you that he knows that
his style is gonna you know hasten his
exit and cause problems is Justin yeah
he has been very very upfront with the
audience and like he is aware of the
cost he is bearing which is unusual most
guys are like somewhat in denial about
it I think that I would take something
of a middle ground on this one where I
do believe that you know he is still
hittable in ways but I think he sets up
his offense much more thoughtfully and I
do think his defense has to an extent
gotten better I guess I would still
favor Poirier I do worry about the
damage that he's accrued over the years
and what that might do to him I don't
know if he's the best boxer in the UFC
whatever that means but I put him on the
short list yeah I put him on the short
list for sure